hi everyone it's jerry i'm on chess.com
i'm going to give two games
or try to get in two games here against
computer impossible this first one i'll
try to play
well as usual try to play solid against
computer in the second game i'm gonna
try the hippopotamus defense
see if i could try and close up the
center and uh
that could turn out to be quite a long
game
okay i'm gonna go with h6 this isn't a
good move because of queen c2 yeah so
why am i doing that exactly i guess i
was playing hope chess
i was hoping that uh the queen c2
wouldn't be there i didn't want to
develop bishop f5 and knight h4
so uh all right we're gonna shift gears
here clearly maybe maybe i could try to
take advantage of the queen's placement
on c2 by getting in the c5 break
kind of get a tempo back with rook to c8
stop knight b5
knight c6
bishop to d bishop to e7
well maybe i want to challenge the dark
square bishop let's see for a moment
yeah let's challenge that guy
see what white does knight knight e5 i
could play queen c7 okay
so i'm not sure what this guy's doing
over here all right i'm not
too uh worried about that move
i've been to one majority in the center
i'm not quite sure why it took so long
with recapturing okay so i'm going to
get the bishop if i really want it
i do have some concern however over my
dark squares
b6 and d6
let's see
i wonder if i could just keep this
tension my first thought is to take a
couple times the queen recaptures
hmm how do i get this guy working
that could be a bit tricky
i wonder if i could uh just castle and
meet e5 with knight here
and then uh maybe
it would kind of be like a french
structure if i do that
just castle e5 knight here but
black or white wouldn't have a d-pawn so
kind of tied to the defensive e5
i'm gonna try that
this castle i'm expecting this no
that's not being played all right
hmm
okay
is there anything wrong with pushing
here e5 just to clear the diagonal for
my bishop
e5 takes
knight takes
ooh i have to be a little bit careful
here because in that variation e5 takes
knight takes
the bishop could always give a check
king h1 and the rook would have pressure
on my knight
my queen would be its only defender and
i can't really rely upon the queen's
placement on c5
there's always these b4 moves
however what about just uh smashing
through on this square a couple times
and then playing e5
hmm
this knight's going to be a pain
takes a couple times queen takes e5
knight c4 and then
pressure on e5 for a third time ids of
knight d6
i wonder if i could just play b5 here
and still keep this tension
b5 basically aiming at keeping the
knight out of play or at least white
would have to work a little bit harder
before he gets into play i'm going to
try that
let's run with it
all right there we go center's closed
not sure how bad this is
i do have pressure on e5 which is being
reinforced
okay
so
hmm what would white want to do next
knight c2 to d4
this bishop on c8 is not the greatest
piece in the world
i wonder if i should be trying to break
here no you know what f as soon as f6 is
played these light squares are going to
be a big problem
but you know what maybe i could play f5
hmm
yeah i'm gonna try that yeah i'm gonna
try f5
it's gonna be closed or not takes knight
takes is my idea okay so the queen it's
gonna remain closed
i guess the main focus with that is to
allow knight c2
hmm
this is interesting
i don't believe my queen belongs on c5
anymore
you know what i would really like to
have happen
knight c5 to here
so let's do that while i can
okay i think i'm going to do that
i i have to be uh cautious of my bishop
here he's again nothing not the greatest
piece in the world
don't know that i want to take
i could maybe consider it
um
now i'm going to keep the tension here
reserve my knight's option as well maybe
i take the bishop maybe i jump in here
okay
so hasn't turned out so bad here all
right i'm gonna back up
certainly one day i want to have my
queen freed up from defending this pun
and now
i may be in a spot to trade queen's
a minute warning here
um all right let's try queen trade why
not not going to come here
not afraid of that i really feel like i
like this position
i really do feel like i like this
position
all right let's get him rolling a little
bit
oh are you serious
what is that
oh man
that is uncalled for
oh man tricky tricky tactics
ah man just when i thought i could
invest some time to make some
positional moves rook takes d5 huh
you sneaky computer
ah man just when i was really liking the
position right no queens on the board
end game sort of closed
is it time to already give up
no way still gonna try to fight
if i could move
okay so here's the big plan that white
has
to uh
to chop the knight up
got b4 coming in
but i'm going to still try my best
let's see oh really
well done
well done
let's grab that guy i guess
i thought i thought i had to take my
knight right away that pond's going to
get pushing or that move
five second warning
not sure what to do
i guess here
ready to get that pawn or this one
yeah it's just not gonna happen not
happening
um
keep pushing this pawn i guess
keep pushing them
i'm done
i'm done let's see the finishing touch
here
there's no way
there's no way to save it
or is there
if i could somehow trade my pawn for one
of their puns i have maybe a chance
maybe
we're gonna see
all right
i'm not sure where to go at my king
ah
hang out for a second
come on just move one of your puns
sneak over here
hmm
now this is actually turning out to be
quite interesting i did not expect uh
and i expect this
hmm
hang on
don't you okay wait a second this is
i have chances here just to draw this
i believe if i had more time i could
definitely draw this but uh
hang on
hang on i want to make sure that king
does what i don't want the king to
advance
i don't care about pinning the pawn i
want to stop the king from advancing so
that's why i'm going to stay here
so i'm going to do
i was not expecting this
i'm sure you heard a lot of doubt in my
voice earlier
just like i was ready to give up
stay focused now look you're just
dancing i'll offer a draw you're gonna
decline that
sneaky player
let's see
i can't do anything but just sit and
wait
please don't go 50 moves
and then make a pawn move that's exactly
what it's going to do
if you did not know
that's exactly what's going to happen
i just want to trade one pawn
and then
i'll know what to do for sure
hopefully you can see that in action
and and hopefully i don't mess that up
all right so
let's see just a little dance back and
forth eventually the king there okay
gotta go here
i want to keep the rooks on get right
back here king position if allowed
maybe i should try to bank some move
fast or bank some time here
round two the second game i'm going to
try to set up the hippopotamus close the
position and then attack on the flanks
stay tuned for that
this is very exciting clearly this
position
you getting dizzy yet i am
all right
25 seconds in the bank
all right where is that tricky move
going to be rook here
all right
this is fantastic stuff right here look
at the technique this computer has
you gotta try something else
you've got to try something else 28
seconds
right here's the plan
again i don't care about pinning the
king
or the pawn to the king i should say
stop the king from moving forward
and i'm staying as far away from the
king as
possible so one of these the abc files
so i could like give checks
if the king tries to go elsewhere
uh let's see we're close to that 50 move
mark and move 91.
good grief
good grief
um
king's gonna have to make a move soon
you know what i've actually seen it uh
just accept a draw at this point without
doing a
like from a 50 mover world without
trying some other pawn move
it's rare but i have seen that before we
have 50 moves yet now
i'll test that out every now and
then um
come on what's he gonna try next
how do i know it's a he
oh my goodness
there it is okay finally finally finally
now what do we do
definitely don't trade
in decision time make sure it's a good
one
all right i'll pin the pawn if i can
if i can't stop the king
i will pin the pawn i'm getting right
back here there we go
ah come on draw
you kidding me you're not accepting a
draw
that's a free pawn
i'm going to take it with my rook what's
wrong with that
nothing after draw
oh now this is unfair this might be the
last time i play this guy
look at
what kind of this what kind of a
sportsmanship is this
this is a draw
except the draw there you go
wow i again was not expecting that okay
let's try it one more 106 moves
time to throw the hippo
at this computer come on play knight c6
i want you to do that
you're gonna do that definitely there we
go
okay
phase one complete make sure the c pun
is blocked in
and it's definitely going to play this
soon right
go here
this could be that game was long but
this one could be even longer
um let's see maybe i want to retain some
flexibility
i don't know maybe this move is going to
be played
i'm just going to pass let's see if he
goes here
all right let's let's give it a whirl
why not so these uh flank pawns are uh
are blocked in the bishop puns
i'm going to go with this
there you go
same 10 moves you're going to push
eventually and i'm going to be prepared
for it
you're gonna push
i'm gonna wait this is a big waiting
game here
so that's why i was saying this could
this could turn out to be an even longer
game come on push one way or the other
d4 i go here
e4 i go here
so what's it going to be
i'm just going to shuffle for a while
and see if it makes a mistake i'm doing
this so that my rook is finally freed up
i'll throw my rook here
and of course watch out for any crazy
tactics boy that first game i really
thought i was busted
really dead
oh that's thinking wow
yeah this is such a such a weird way to
try and get uh
some activity
you know i could drop my bishop back
like if rook here
trying for some fancy tricks against my
unprotected bishop i could come back
what about
and just shuffle it's time to shuffle
maybe
yeah it's not really working out how i
wanted it it's it's being a bit patient
and you usually it goes for something
like this this is strictly
playing against computer type play here
um
just playing much more patient i don't
like that come on commit
you know you want to push one of these
guys you see you got nothing
you've got nothing what did you really
try to do is like throw the knight on h6
get this pawn involved and then jump
back over here
this isn't it isn't working out though
is it
maybe knight g1 f3 to h4 maybe i could
try some active
plan i'll give it a i'll give it a some
more time though to slip up
would we really have to go 50 moves
before it makes a pawn advance
maybe we could do that
maybe i'll i'll try to show off my
patience here
but uh
yeah i don't know what really more to
say
knight g1 i could try
knight g1 just to reinforce this pawn if
for some reason there was more uh
pressure put on it with like knight h7
to g5
i don't want to move him that gives up a
really good square on g4
so
yeah another thing okay so i made a pawn
move which is really doing nothing of
these two pawn advances the one that i
would really like to see
is d4
because then i could play e4 and then
hopefully try to one day get some space
on the king's side that's where it could
really fall apart so this is
clearly turning out to be a marathon
or maybe even a record-setting number of
moves type of game
i could do other things besides move my
queen but i want to keep my knights
right here
again anticipating one of these two pawn
moves
hopefully we could see this in action
all right
not going with either these advances hmm
hmm
how does this change things if at all
i'm not quite sure
i think if
if b4 i'm definitely going a4
if a4 i'll go
b4 and then maybe even try to lock down
on this c5 square
not quite sure
move 34.
oh okay so we finally have some action
it didn't happen in this game oh well i
tried
i'm gonna have to go in a different
direction clearly so
that wasn't
too long i don't think move 34. 34
finally have some
decision points
all right let's go with b4
bishop's got to go back
and now
hmm
i wonder
okay i'm going to try something with
my knight let's go to g1
maybe f3 in here
maybe i could slightly improve my
queen position
you know what the one thing i have to be
a bit concerned about is this knight
moving and then c5
i wonder if i could do something against
that like as soon as the night moves
maybe then i'll take some action in the
center
one thing that i'm uh
trying to stay away from is after like
well if if i play this move ever the
knight is going to jump in here really
really quick
um oh you know what i could do i could
probably get this rook over here on the
e file
how should i go about that queen e2
rook here and then queen of d1 or queen
b1 queen a2 i think i like this better
i i'm i'm reluctant to throw my queen
opposite that rook oh man
what do you think you're doing over here
all right let's try to get this in
this move i'm gonna play oh yes there we
go
that's what i'm talking about
okay so it finally did it it pushed in
the center so
if i do this right away he turns out to
be a tall pawn
nobody wants to see that so i think
anticipating that this will be
a closed position i'm gonna give up my
bishop
who cares
about bishops in such a closed position
with eight pawns each here
well i gotta try to keep it close are
this oh there's gonna be that sack
that's what i was just gonna say
that crazy sack there it goes again
these unexpected
tricks
ah man
i'm crunched
can i salvage this one too i don't think
it's gonna happen
i'm gonna give it a shot though
all right what am i thinking about he's
gotta go i'm not giving pawns away for
free
um yeah
not the first time i've seen that type
of sack either one where
black gives up the knight for two pawns
but there's gonna be a third one won
hmm let's see
can i try you know what i might be able
to trick it
yeah it's no it's gonna take my rook i
wanna
i don't wanna go into a position where
i'm down three pounds for the knight
i'd rather play one words rook and two
pawns for two minor pieces
so hopefully i could try to hold this
it's going to open up further not much i
could do about it bishop takes queen
takes and then e3 is gonna happen
well we're gonna have to try oh
you're not going with that are you
hmm
okay
what about i throw my queen right in the
center
and uh
yeah i'm gonna try that
super glue that queen right here on d4
she can't be dislodged so easily or can
she
look at this computer offering queen
trades
wow
who would have thunk it
all right let's come over here
centralize the king a bit more oh
i feel like i should be able to
um
consolidate
what about queen here
uh
let's try queen here
ah i could get this move in
how am i doing oh i'm not doing so great
on the clock
i get my
night working better
whoa i just gotta move
move fast okay i have a uh they're gonna
get that pump pushing
where are they rook here
no that's not good
why am i moving my knight somewhere else
other than d4 do i really think there's
a better square than d4 for my knight
maybe i could hunt down this pawn
i have a dark square blockade or so i
thought
oh man
why wasn't i moving just then
queen trade
this pawn is a dead duck oh my goodness
is he dead
i gotta put pressure on this pawn
i had to defend 83 that's why i did that
i can't lose on time anything but losing
on time it's just
i cannot allow that to happen
okay knight here i'm hammering away at
that pawn
as best i can have every piece on that
offer a draw
oh man
does that sound like i'm scared oh i'm
on this pond now how you defending
are you defending this pun
i didn't want to take it right away
ah it's closed again
i love closed positions against the
computer
oh
i gotta defend i lost in time
oh man well i tried it got closed up you
see how it ended up committing
it took forever to do that
but i re i wanted this i wanted to give
it a shot that first game
was a real one this one was just
strictly against a computer
playing against computer scene trying to
get it to close up it did do that
i guess um
there's just some computer ideas
involved with this one like um
when it did in fact go for that
sacrifice
to know not to
let's say
right here
uh i guess a computer tip to not
to not try to play it out where it's
you're down three pawns for the night
but rather
because because in that way it's uh what
can we say it's
it's a balanced balanced material but
with this space advantage
it's just going to be too much
this is a perfect example where the this
computer at least will go for
bishop takes knight but maybe this is in
fact the
the more uh well the objectively best
move to go in and grab upon instead of
uh the exchange at this point i was able
to obtain that dark square blockade
i wonder what a computer evaluation be
saying on this maybe some of you can
share that piece of information
um
i'll be sure to include the pgn in the
description for this second game and for
those that are
interested you could maybe give some
feedback as to what it's saying about
this final position even somewhere right
around here
but uh yeah it got to be pretty closed i
like to have my knight on this square
and having a lockdown on this
this f5 advance
what just happened there that was about
the end of the game there but yeah i
ended up losing on time unfortunately it
was just too much for me to have to
watch over although you know what at
this point here
i couldn't defend the pawn that's
actually a big problem isn't it maybe i
won't include
maybe i won't include the pgn but
um yeah what can you do knight a2 i'd be
dropping a3 in this final position
wasn't just it wasn't just wasn't
working out
oh well i'll have to try uh another time
at least i got away with the draw on
that first game and as always i hope you
got something on this video take care
bye
you